Our mean difference as you found earlier is negative 2.72. For the lower bound
we'll subtract the T critical value times the standard error, we found before
that the T critical value is 2.064 when there are 24 degrees of freedom. And
then we'll multiply this by S the standard deviation of the differences. divide
by the square root of 25. This gives us about negative 4.24, then we'll do the
same for the upper bound of this confidence interval. Negative 2.72 plus 2.064
times 3.69 divided by the square root of 25. If we round to the hundreths
place, this gives us negative 1.20. We can conclude then, by saying that on
average, users will make around four to one fewer errors on the QWERTY keyboard
than on the alphabeticle keyboard.